Hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with your brief information for today, Monday
, April 19, Clark County leaders
will vote tomorrow for a
reopening plan that will take effect on
May 1st, this is how this plan includes changes such
as allowing 10 people at the
same table  restaurant or give the
green light to the steps to reopen their
doors,
minimizing restrictions on
public gatherings and events for those who
have already received the vaccine will also be discussed. It should be remembered
that the governor announced the reopening
of the state to 100% capacity for  on
June 15
from today arts and if you will be
offering free transportation for
people who must attend their appointments
to receive the
coronavirus vaccine these passes can be
found in your application and can be
picked up in person or sent by
mail the  trips will be available
through the end of may
the thunderbirds will take to the skies of the
valley when they return home is  This afternoon
from Florida the team returns to their
shows after a year of inactivity
between noon and 1 pm today
the thunderbirds will fly from the west
over henderson and green valley and then head
towards the las vegas suite
back to  the base area of ​​ships
now we pass with the
weather forecast a sunny day is expected with
temperatures above normal the
maximum will be in the high 80 degrees
until Tuesday have a good day I
am shalicar friend with your brief
informative for edition in Spanish
[Music]